Az
[Alkış]
önceki Hoşgeldiniz hepiniz
kalbim yerinden çıkacak mı söylemek
istiyorum Çok heyecanlıyım İlk defa
sahneye çıkıyorum böyle saniye çıkmadı
örnek olarak etek teşekkür ediyorum
Buket hocam gibi çok hızlı konuşan
bileyim elimden geldiği kadar tane tane
anlatacağım hikayemi bi Öncelikle benim
anlatacağım hikaye Aslında tamamen bir
çoğumuzun hayatında olabilecek Hatta
Çocuğunuz varsa çocuklarımızın bir ton
yaşayabileceği standartlarda bir hikaye
olacak
benim için çok Extreme değil fakat
birçok insan çok Extreme olacak hikaye
yaşıyorum ve bir yere geliyorum Şu anda
benim kalbimin en başında kesinlikle şu
yatıyor
bu lise bittikten sonra ben İstanbul
Tamam üniversite kazandım ve Marmara ver
Size gittikten sonra Pardon gitmeden
önce süreçte
uzun yıllarca bak Müzik yaptım bu grup
bir grupla beraber yüzlü acaba binlerce
kontrol çıktık de malzemeler yaptık
Besler yaptık
Hep arayışı içerisindeydim ya Hayat hep
araçla geçti bu arayış içerisinde hep
sanat hayatının yanında vardı fakat
belki sanat olduğunu bilmiyordum bile
yani ve uğraştım çabaladım ve Mert
Elektronik Bölümü gittikten iki ay sonra
kaşık öğrenci işlerine gidip pastanem
aldığımı okumadım Marmara
Üniversitesi'nde çalıştı İstanbul'da
8-10 sona kadar İstanbul'da
Mağazacılık ödemediği arkadaşımın
anlattığı gibi Mağazacılık yaptığım çok
uzun süre DJ'lik yaptım gece
kulüplerinde yapılarda çaldım bu süreçte
tabi İstanbul'daki bu süreçte ben çok
fazla insan tanıdım çok fazla insanla
birlikte oldum en çok ortama girdim 40
yaşındayım Yaklaşık 40 yaşın yarısı
diyebilirim 20 yıl kadar süreçte hep
sanat yanında oldu bu sanat dediğim
kısım fotoğraf çekmek değildi asla
fotoğraf çekmiyorum fotoğraf hayatımın
15 yılında o Yaklaşık 15 yıldır vardı bu
hikayenin Aslında çocuklara verdim yani
sizin hepimizin hayatında olacak kısmı
Aslında şöyle bir insan düşünün ve bu
insan hep Çalışkan olmayan lise ve
ortaokul ulaşım öğrenci değildim hep
spor uğraştım yıllarca Basketbol oynadım
Belki daha iyi yönlendirir sevdim çok
iyi basketbol olabilirdim ama öyle bir
şey olmadığı müzik Hayatının bir yerinde
vardı bu hayatımın Aslında anlattığım
kısmı bu hikayenin en son kısmı asla
sizin duracağız kısım bu değil Ben en
baştan başlamak istiyorum İstanbul'a
gittikten sonraki süreçte Metropol
yaşamında bir 8-10 sene kadar çok uzun
süre Beyoğlu gibi kalabalık yerlerde
çalıştım orayı en büyük marka vermeyeyim
en büyük markalar da mağazalarda mağaza
müdürleri görsel sandalye uzmanlığı gibi
işler yaptım bu görsel sanatlardan
kastım renk skalası neden tutulur işte
Konuşma diksiyona kadar bunları
eğitimleri verdiler bana insanlar Demek
ki bir şey görmüş takip adını vermişler
O
benim bu süreçte şunu söylemek istiyorum
birçoğunuzun öldür eminim ailem annem
babam ve ablam özellikle hep yanında
vardı Hep destek oldular onların desteği
olmasaydı asla böyle bir ev aramazdım
Çünkü şu anda yaptığım şey kesimde
Popüler Kültür bir şey yapmıyorum
dağlara çıkıyorum bataklıklara gidiyorum
hatta eksi derecelere geliyor gidiyorum
Demir arkada gördüğünüz bu yağmurluk ve
Samanyolu'nun olduğu videoyu çekmek için
dağlara çıkıp günlerce belki haftalarca
-25 eksi derecelerde Termal içlikler LV
onlar ya çekmeye çalıştım ama bunlar
hiçbir maddi kaybı olduğunu düşünerek
yaptım ya Maddi çıkar gözetmeden bu iş
yaptım
ya Sonuç olarak bu maddiyat gözetmeden
yani çok severek yaptığım için bir gün
bir yere gelmesi Hatta şu an bu sahne
çıkmış olmam bile benim için büyük bir
Onur verici olduğunu verici birşey
hiçbir şey beklemeden hiçbir şeyi Umut
etmeden sadece severek yaptığım bir
şeyin Coşkun Aral gibi bu tanımıyorum
ama Coşkun hocam elinden alabileceğim en
güzel ödüllerden birini aldım geçen sene
bu ödülün dışında tayın Gökhan Bey'in
sayesinde Vali bir sayesinde 3-4 tane
sergi yaptık bu sergi tamamen Adana Doğa
ve kuşlarla alakalıydı ta Ben 2 yıldır
yaklaşık Afrika'dan Türkiye'ye gelen
adam özellikle gelen bizimle günlerimize
da alanlarımıza gelen kuşları
gözlemliyorum Dışarıdan bakıldığında şu
çok söylüyorlar bu cümleyi ya sana güzel
hayat sana güzel renkleri kısmında Ben
bükme bataklığın içinde sağlıkla
yılanları falan kol yolluyorum ve bu
benim Çünkü keyif o ayrı çok kişi
korkuyor biliyorum ama ben yılandan
akrepten korkmadan değilim çünkü inanın
Onlar bizden daha çok korkuyorlar daha
çok kaçıyorlar gidiyorlar
bu sürecin Son attığım gibi benim
İstanbul'a gitme serüveninde
dediğim gibi sınavsız geçişle gittiğimiz
beklemeden bir Anadolu İstanbul hayatım
benim İstanbul'da çok düştüm çok kalk
daha fazla ortama girdim fakat çok da
iyi olmayan bir ruh haliyle ve İstanbul
takip adına yeniden dönme kararı aldım
tak Adana'ya geldiğinde adının
coğrafyasını doğasının Bu mükemmel
olduğunu bilmiyordum tekrar söyleyeceğim
bir ara içerisindeydim ve bu aracı ne
olduğunu bilmiyordum tembel bir
öğrenciydim ve çalışkan olmadım Bu
Arayışın
Adana'ya gelmesini Benim de bu arayış
içerisinde adına geldikten sonra uzun
bir süre kendini kapattım hayata
İnterneti kapattın telefonu olmadı Çünkü
bu şekilde gelmiştim Adana'ya
bir şekilde Anlamadığım şekilde ben kan
hayatına başladım dağlarda kalp yaptım
ve beni tanıyan çoğu arkadaşım tek
başıma Kanka yapma gittim çok iyi
bilirler Ben kanguru bana gitmem girmem
tek başıma giderim kampa orada öğrendim
hayvanlardan korkmadığını Doğan daha
güzel bir yer olduğunu
İstanbul'dan o kadar sıkıntılı şekilde
adına gelip kendimizi var çekip
sonrasında bazı kanyonları tek başıma
kamp yapmaya gibi kafamı dinlemek
istediğim süreçte de eşimle Evet Ee
tekrar söylüyorum kendisinde burada
duyma göremiyorum Ama hayatımda Türkan
Hanım olmasaydı asla Ben burada
Olamazdım en büyük destekçim diyebilirim
Ayrıca eşime Bütün kadınların da kadar
güçlü olduğunu çocuğum olduktan sonra
fark ettim iki tane çocuğum var
İkizlerim oldu işte önce bizim adı Ekin
diğerinin adı Doğa ve ben ekinde doğaya
bizden sonraki hayatta bakın böyle bir
coğrafya var demek için Aslında bu
fotoğraflar çekmeye başladım fark ettim
çünkü anlıyorsunuz ne olduğunu ben ablam
da yaşın 40'lı yoruma istersin 15
civarındayken adanın Bir Köyünde yaşardı
kaslar hataylıyım burada ama Adana doğma
büyüme yi düşünün ben bu tarafta düğme
bu hafta yaşadığım her şeyi
ablamla şu anki rezidansların olduğu şu
anki binaların olduğu yerlerde Ekin
tarlaları vardı biz gerçekten ablamla
iktidarların uğur böceği topladık işte
yan Bahçeden marul toplayıp soframıza
koyardım bu çocuk göremeyecek bir
ihtimal böyle yaşadık böyle büyüdük dua
et içinde vardı hayatınızda Sen bugün
kaç noktam oldu bu hikaye nasıl en daha
önce kısmı zaten ben İstanbul'dan
Adana'ya gelmeye bir şekilde karar
vermem ve getirilen değil hani detaya
girmeyeyim bir şekilde geldim adamı ya
İkide gelmiştim ya gelmeseydin Ben büyük
ihtimalle İstanbul'da büyük barlarda
barmenlik yapıyor işte isimde
verebilirim müfettişler sizi tabi
sayesinde ben çok şey öğrendim şu an
Irmak çağıracağım sayesinde bu ders
aldım Diğerleri çok komik Bu insanlarla
iki tane dön düşünüyorum asla
İstanbul'daki Peki çıkıyorum büyük
Metropol görmek istemiyorum Çünkü
yaşadığım yerler yeniden geldiğimde
gördüm ki gördüm ki bütün o tarlalar
bütün o ağaçlar hepsi kesinleşmesi bina
olmuş durumda Yani ben aslında bir anı
ölümsüzleştiren geçmişin Yaşadığım
şeyleri de bu anı kapak istemiştim Bunu
fark ettim ama işin en güzel tarafı
yıllarca Yani 12 yıldır bu arada ben
fotoğraf çekmeye Makro Fotoğrafçılık
başladım Bir kelebeğin ayağını bir kuşun
ağzındaki böceği minik şeyler çekerek
başladım fotoğraf çekmeye ve bu Hobi
olarak yaptığım Aslında kendimi bulduğum
ve yaklaştı şöyle düşünebilirsiniz
meditasyon yapmaya bilmiyorum Çok alakam
yok ama benim için meditasyon gibi
birşeymiş Aslında doğaya çıkmak kamp
yapmak kuş çekmek
benim Hobi olarak yapmaya çalıştığım
şeyi bir şekilde ya bu adam kuş
çekebiliyor sana ve hatta Bu adam gece
Samanyolu çekebiliyor Sabir ürün
çekebilir bir ya da bir mekan tanıtım
klibi yapabilir deyip hocalarım abilerim
Hatta şu an bu şekilde tam bir ekip var
Mm çok sevdiğim arkadaşlarım onları da
sayesinde
birkaç yıldır ticari olarak kendini
gönderebileceğim bir hayata çevirdim bu
işi yıllarca çok büyük holdinglerde fon
yönetim Lipo yöneticiliği
bilgisayar Apple gibi büyük firmalarda
eğitim departmanı satış departmanı
depoculuk düşer yaptım ama İstanbul'da
yaşarken
garsonluk yaptım DJ'lik yaptım dediğim
gibi yani o da mafyasında gördüm en en
büyük hareketinde gördüğüm en aşağısında
gördüm işiniz olarak ben hobimi eğerti
Ne söylediysem burada gene çocukluğuma
tam bir durum var Çocukluğumda
Babam ve annemin beni çok yönlendirmesi
diyeceğim onlara kızmayacağım Çünkü
onlar da bilmiyormuş böyle bir şey
olacağını Bence çocuklarımızı gerçekten
çok fazla
bitti ederek değil de onu biraz daha
serbest bırakarak onları yapabilecek şey
görecek bir şey yönlendirecek daha biz
olabileceğini biliyorum ben kaç yaşında
fark ettim bunu keşke 35 lira fark
etmedim ki üniversite bitirdim burada
manası okumadım ama iki üniversite
mezunuyum ama iki üniversite okuma
halinde bilgiler oluyor Bazıları bana
kızıyor bazı Ama keşke daha başta
meslekle başlasaydım diye bunu
düşünüyorum bu durumu Yani sonuç olarak
ben hala dur da son iki yıldır aktif
olarak kuş çeken bir adamın profesyonel
bir kuşu saf değilim ama herkesin
sayısını arttırdım nesli tükenmekte olan
kuşları çekiyorum buradaki onu
araştırıyorum günlerce
kum fırtınasında kaldığımı olduğu
Yüzümün parçalandığı olduğu ama benim
canım yapıyor bunlarda ne yapmalı Çok
keyif aldım kendimi zaten Bazen kuş gibi
düşünüyorum Çünkü o kadar Özgür
hayvanlar ki tilki gördüm domuz gördüm
abi gördüm çakal gördüm çakalın yuvasına
gidiyorum yani orada fotoğrafını koymaya
çalışıyorum ama çakallar türküler inanın
Biz insanlardan daha duyarlı hayvanlar
daha duyarlı varlıklar hayvanları Yanlış
oldu Kusura bakmayın lütfen
Ben kendimi bir kuş türü görmeye
çalışıyorum ve onlar gibi olmaya
çalışıyorum bu süreçte
34 daha sergi yapıldı bu sayede büyük
insanların ya bizim birleşik insanların
gelip sergimizi gelmesinin dışında kalan
kısımda binlerce Öğrenci geldi bu
öğrencilerin birçoğu kırsaldan
köylerden şey hayatım giyinmeye
insanlarda ve bir seçtik bu insanları
bana gelip On yaşında bir çocuğun
Alperen abi işte bir kızılgerdan koşup
burada mı yaşıyor ya bu hayvan burada mı
bir gökkuzgun kuşu masmavi kuş ya burada
mı yaşıyorlar silah net görmüyoruz
dediklerinde hep şu cümleyi kullandığım
Aslında hepsi peşimizde şöyle at 12'nin
dikkatli Bakın ben iki gün önce oraya 28
çektim Atatürk Parkı içerisinde ve HES
aslında uzun yaşayan Kuşlar Florya kuşu
de kuş var sapsarı dört tane yuvasını
buldum Atatürk Parkı'ndan ama şey
yapmazlar hayvanlar ama yapıyorlarmış
Bunu fark ettim
Kuşlar benim için çok önemli olduğunu
fark ettim ve çocukların gelip bana
bunları sorması ve kuşlarla beraber ya
Adana'da böyle Kanyon mu var böyle bir
havuz var Gizli havuz dediklerinde daha
neler var Keşfedilmemiş bunu bölgesinde
dediğinde abi konum verme olur diyorlar
ben konum paylaşmıyorum Bana çok kızıyor
çok kızıyor Bununla ilgili kurum asla
paylaşmıyor Çünkü benim kalp mantığı
mangal yapmak değil ben etkili
bitiriyorum gittiğimi asla bir avuç
fındık fıstık Lara hafta geçiyorum
orucun kokuyor hayvanlar geliyor sizin
adınıza Yani işin özü sonrasında Ben şu
anda ve halihazırda ticari olarak
fotoğrafçılıkla
bitiriyorum hayatım bunu idare
ettiriyorum ama işin Özünde her
boşluğunda Hatta şu an bu bittikten
sonra hazır arabamda çadırım atın her
şeyi duruyor Ben kaçıp gideceğim büyük
ihtimal 3-4 günü dalga çıkacağım çok
insan gördüm için büyük muhabbeti koca
katılıyorum İstanbul'un bana verdiğin
bir program tanesi fazla insan fazla
yüzden hep zarar verdi çok konuşan bir
insanım Çok düşerken bir sana değilim O
yüzden azizhan özyılsan değil dağlara
çıkmaya karar verdim bilmiyorum bakar
öncesi sonrası anlatabildim hiç
çalışmadım Burada en doğru çalıştığını
söyleyemem ablam babam yazar benim
Onların fikrini alarak birazcık buraya
geldim hangi Point bir yazıydı
hazırlamadım olabildiğince doğal olmaya
çalıştım sizlere
benim konuşma bu kadar beni dinlediğin
Teşekkür ederim çok sağ olun eksik
olmayın
Çok sağolun kız
Son olarak şunu söyleyeceğim Sadece
bende Arkadaşlar rica ettim eğer
mümkünse diye sağolsun kabul ettiler
berkush çekmenin dışında bir önceki
hayatımda yani kuştan Bir önceki
fotoğraf hayatında astrofotoğraf alan
Merak sardım astrofotoğraf da şu Bu
bir fotoğraf makinesinin Aslında
gökyüzündeki bir yılda çekileceğini fark
ettim Bunu herkes yapabilir Çok zor
değil mi bakıyor her şey bunu
keşfettikten Sonra dedim ki ya bu
fotoğraf nasıl video olmuştur Yani bir
göktaşı yağmuru nasıl kayıyor ben Bu
nasıl gösterebilirim insanlar ben Bu
nasıl kayıt altına alabilir uğraştım
yeni hocalarım abilerim Sora sora Yani
bir şekilde öğrenme deneme yanılma
yöntemiyle bunu öğrendim ben bütün işi
yaptıktan sonra sizi çok seviyoruz
edeceğim Bu video aladağ'ın yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam mavi Yaylasının yapışık
2000-2500 metre kılındığı bir yerde -15
derecede Çünkü bunu açmak istiyorum nem
olmaması gerekiyor Bu işte nem Yağmur
Bulut ayısı olması gerekiyor hepsi
araştırarak defalarca deneme yöntemi
yaparak yaptığım bir video bu bütün
Türkiye'de paylaşıldı size ne görmesini
istiyorum Bu video meteor yağmurunun
olduğu bir çekilmiş video at video değil
yaklaşık bir 10000 fotoğraftan oluşan
tanesi fotoğraf videosudur
benim en zorlandığım şey 37 ama iş
bittikten sonra o video izlerken
inanılmaz mutlu olmuştum sizin
izleyeceğiniz bu 30 saniyelik video
benim dört buçuk saatimi aldı
diyebilirim 400 saat boyunca -15
derecede
makinamız tarafına basıp 400-500 metre
arkaya uzağa 17 Çünkü telefon ışığının
olması gerekiyor Ateş yapacaksınız
ateşimizin kalıcı geçmemesi gerekiyor
yaklaşık 45 saati an tepesinde yaptığım
bir Samanyolu galaksisinin tam bir
meteor yağmurunu giriş videosu
izleyeceksiniz Tekrar çok teşekkür
ediyorum beğendiğiniz için kafanızı
Sizden özür diliyorum Çok sağolun o
[Müzik]
o o
abone ol